hey everyone welcome back to grave
hoppers the show where we put permit us
in every game I'm like my Hardy here
with Rob handler hey and let's jump
right into it let's check out what
happened last week when our guest Mary
Kish was still here
previously on grave hunters if you die
in the game you move on to another one
my plan is to do some shrines get some
salmon I get some hearts and then take
on Ganon so will you go get joy see it's
like one hit it's one slip horses can't
do they hurt you they kick you I think
they just run away they can totally kick
you kill that person and then tickets
was great to choose but we roll oh yeah
knock him off there's one
I would not be jumping you know me
pump it up oh I smell a car you stupid
[Laughter]
okay it's a lizard so these guys really
soccer
he'll alert the other one around over
here yeah oh he's fast
you don't know good job
oh good job okay yes yes oh God
nice job cool let's call it there okay
[Music]
well there were a few close brushes last
time Marrakesh thanks for filling in
people if you are noticing right now we
are no longer recording the show live we
found out that it kind of makes more
sense for us to record this and then
just put it up it's always gonna be the
same time 2 p.m. on every Thursday but
we felt like a bunch of people were
still kind of catching up so we wanted
to just kind of publish at 2:00 p.m. and
that way you don't have to worry about
catching it live but we do still want
like you guys to participate as you can
see we're getting toward the end of our
list Rob's in Legend of Zelda and you've
seen the list a few times before after
this we're gonna do Metal Gear Solid 5
Ground zeroes and then maybe if I beat
that because that's shorter than going
to phantom pain but that games got a
long intro that will probably skip for
you and then alien isolation but as
always we put permits in every game so
next time Robb dies in breath of the
wild we're gonna move into ground zeroes
so an hour from when Robb starts playing
today I'm back I was traveling back in
New York France yes it was a good trip
work trip half work half family stuff
but Mary was kind enough to really [ __ ]
up my res neo for playthrough I was
watching that live but anyway brutal
yeah so we were talking about what
you're gonna do in Zelda I've been I've
been catching up that last time I saw
you had a Cupid's elf those encounters
that almost yeah killed you so you're
you said you're gonna try to a a because
shrines kind of get boring if you're
watching but also you want to keep just
stocking up on items and food rather
than up in your hearts and stamina so
yeah this uh this is the way I see it
okay until right now we're recording on
Wednesday you have one hour from right
now hmm
so 4:16 p.m. you have to survive until
all go on to Zelda near the show he'll
be keep he'll keep playing Zelda if he
doesn't die but if he does die it's my
turn to play
so yeah so here's the way I see it we're
gonna put some restrictions on this play
because I'm doing pretty well this is
the longest run we're at what like
almost two hours now
the way I see it is it's still gonna be
the same end game which is I gotta beat
Ganon but I'm gonna put some more
restrictions on what I'm gonna do is not
do any shrines so I'm not gonna get any
more hearts I'm not gonna get any more
stamina wheels I'm just gonna try to get
currently this episode which I would
imagine would take maybe an hour I just
want to get temporary temporary hearts
and stamina so like poach or like food
and meals and [ __ ] right okay so I'm
gonna go back here and the other thing
is that's pretty much it so like maybe
upgrade like great fairy stuff upgrade
armor I mean not in this episode but I
think so
I think that would be the only other
thing and maybe buy some more armor I
only have I only had enough for a
stealth piece which seemed realistic and
in Kakariko village you could do the
Hylian set or the stealth set and it all
seemed so would you be going for divine
beast to make a man easier I don't know
what do you think like I I could do that
I want to beat the game that would make
sense right but sorry keep going you're
saying oh no it's like the divine beasts
might I think they're short enough where
we won't get completely it'll be still
interesting to watch those are still
pretty fun and they're shorter than the
normal Zelda dungeon excluding Skyward
Sword maybe yeah I changed my mind I'm
gonna go back oh I can't go here yet so
crap I should have gone you're why can't
you go to Kakariko cuz I don't have what
stall oh yeah you're trying to bust that
stallion we ended with but stall because
of the finite amount of letters you can
do so here's another thing as someone in
the comments was again like I'm reading
all those comments because they're gonna
do they're actually giving us tips one
tip it was so da is that you go to great
fairy fountains and get fairies you get
a berry so if I actually lose all my all
my heart so that's like your far cry 5
Ally saving you a little bit yeah I mean
it's that's still legal yeah I mean yeah
I yeah so I'm gonna go do that that's
the first thing I'm gonna do because my
god
again the fastest horse yeah he's pretty
good I still gotta work with max 5 stars
I believe so it's a pending on like the
color scheme of the horse to like it's
like all one color they're generally
faster yeah so we'll talk with ferry
maybe I can get some upgrades but like I
would just be on my stealth fit
yeah I've been relying on stealth seeing
as its master mode yeah definitely
earlier like he is not tamed so yeah
yeah definitely avoiding big encampments
of problems and mob --lens lizalfos
freaking stuff yeah they're like tough
to read when they're attacking they are
there's just superfast to like they're
kind of hard to uh the guy is bomb I was
- oh [ __ ] damn well one of those kill
you in one hit dude I think so yeah like
you Sophie I mean you have three hearts
three hearts yeah a lot of arrows right
now as well I was dumb man oh this worst
man what's wrong why did what did he why
does affection just show he's ran into a
wall face-first
oh I was cuz I was petting on right now
so he's still not into me so yeah the
other thing I was going to say is I
guess that's basically it like fairies
is the plan I'm gonna get a shrine or at
least just turn on the shrine so I could
warp to it oh the other handicap is that
I cannot warp out of combat like at any
point you can warp I didn't think the
game even let you do that now you can
really yeah
I wonder why they allowed that because
most games that's like a default thing
like don't are you getting core exceeds
by the way um cuz that what those would
help right was wouldn't they're quick
and I don't use passed on yeah I mean if
you if the idea is to build up your
inventory then you're getting more slots
by doing core exceeds yeah [ __ ] I love
this game so much
as everybody does I mean the other thing
I could get which would be really
helpful is the stasis upgrade so I could
freeze enemies I can't do that right now
how do you get that you go to her party
he come from
oh whoa houston here lazin but Perot
will do that but you have to do a bunch
of stuff like I don't know like there
are a lot of things you can do but I I
think I'm gonna try to like avoid some
of the boring stuff just for the sake of
well not the stream anymore but the
video like I want to make a challenging
to cuz that's kind of the name of the
show like you yeah we do make it tougher
than than just normal yeah this game is
tough but sometimes it's like the
moments where it's tough right come back
less frequently than in Dhoom learn
really like this game just watching you
play I mean rupees do I have 70 know I
could like I got some house which is
good
oh so you got the sheikah chest torso
yeah
and shield actually why would that's
more I said anybody's got mind's eyes
the shield yeah that's chic on logo yeah
you're right I like the lens of truth
logo yeah
so yeah I'll turn this on surely the
stamina stuff is really tricky - oh yes
you want to activate those for a fast
travel right it's not the three hearts
that worries me it is the really low
stamina again oh for sure yeah and when
I was fine with meri there are a couple
moments we're like I couldn't get away
like you have to you have to you have to
take some sacrifices like as far as
timing you can't just sprint away and
having played so much this game I've had
full stamina wheels for a while right
like so I'm it's like in a [ __ ] dirt
bike place Skyward Sword I did not so
what you know how so that's the first
blue Ruby you've ever gotten right
that's why in Skyward Sword each time
like went back to low to save they would
do that with any item like green rupee
maybe not green here for that might be
exaggerating but like like that items
you've gotten many times before yeah
yeah I remember when I first start
playing this game that was my fear was
like a my goodness am I gonna get this
every [ __ ] time again this guy in the
YouTube chat oh four fairies there were
just three like this is clutch but I
don't know like again so what would you
say will be like what is Ganon ready in
your opinion like how many more weapons
etc what armor for the purposes of this
playthrough yeah you're right on weapons
I haven't I haven't put too much thought
into weapons because when you stun him
and have to wail on him with you know
like but what what especially those
lesson law and I have is garbage I mean
you need a lot of arrows for Ganon
yeah ancient arrows but like I think I
have to go all the way to dr. Robbie to
do that
oh yeah just to get to the castle right
there's a lot of Guardians on the way oh
god I didn't even think about that yeah
like I give her a hundred oh this sucks
oh just to get her to come out
yeah and then you use materials to
arrive have you gotten to the salesman
on skull Lake yet with who he trades his
name is he's like the monster mines kill
ttan yeah no I haven't gone there yet
that's an interesting idea - oh you know
what I could get is the Majora's Mask
that that'll enemies will ignore me oh
how do you get that it's in the DLC it
came with it I that's I know where that
is
I should get that okay Guardians with
Sol messing up that I mean it'll only do
so much Oh Guardians don't fall for it
nope and Lionel's don't but you can get
a line on mash yeah it's a little bit
like eventually they see it I kind of
skipped some this I want to see what I
would need are you've already switched
shirt
oh I can't do this yeah I missed it I
just got the nice shades yeah I'm sure
they put those around this found on
purpose mm-hmm there's nicely done
either silent princess
so if I had all these upgraded stealth
up and double armor yeah if I get one
more star to to each of the three pieces
then it's like I get the set bonus okay
are you do you even have any other piece
on no I have what was in this shrine of
resurrection so some dirty old worn
pants and I still just love the default
Hylian hood that you can wear not at all
but it's my favorite favorite said
despite at night the champions tunic is
like the look for this game but the hood
is the one I warp the most the champions
tunic I could get how do you get it you
know it's it's I thought her story
related lots of mentors
I'm gonna go talk to is there any
benefit to finding those photographs
places yeah I can't remember and but
Impa is the one that gives me the
champions tunic which I might want by I
forget how I'm gonna talk to real quick
there's a point where I thought all
these shrines were like anagrams of like
there's one that looked like it's owl
Numa mixed up oh yeah so I was I don't
know I tried looking at like no I don't
think that checks out also when you get
the korrok mask and you can hear them
there's [ __ ] there's one around here
that took me forever to find and every
time I want to talk to em PI I heard it
the noise
yeah the cork mask I don't think she
wants me go to a tango village that's to
meet the pair of scientists yeah and his
so much I could be doing
all right so why don't I go now he's a
[ __ ]
should I get I guess I should get that
Majora's Mask that'll be helpful I guess
that's probably but yeah that well
making everything else easier to get
yeah and then and then I'll go too
so there's an area where there's a bunch
of Hardy durians and that those were the
best bang for you buck
as far as temporary hearts you cook you
cook one and it's like max health is it
a mushroom or something a durian is like
it's like a stinky fruit I don't know
exactly what the durian is in their
highest but they're all in the
rainforests area got selfish yeah I
remember just like ones this for game
first came out or actually the whole
year after it came out we kept finding
some I found that there wasn't much to
do with it but like I texted you I was
like did you find this beach village yet
and you had played like 70 hours at that
point it's so easy to yeah I remember
like freaking out about that um okay I
kind of want to stable god this is so
difficult
like I don't want to mess this up I
think there's a stable here what don't
you mess up I just don't want to run to
a guardian I'm terrified of that yeah I
think this is best bad
those fairies are clutch how many did
you get four four so you could die four
times
yeah well four and then you have one
more five times five times you lose but
like if you've seen videos man like you
can slip it like it doesn't even have to
be an enemy it's me being an idiot
climbing a wall or something or they're
on a high enough cliff and you fall and
you hit like a Ledge it'll use a ferry
and then you could keep falling you keep
draining ferries real quick
Lionel's and guardians I'm terrified of
I want to have a horse so that's like
some tougher lizalfos on master mode oh
yeah gold gold dudes yeah okay so I'm
pretty sure it's just Guardian territory
it is I guess okay so it's here is the
mask mask yeah wasn't there when the DLC
came out don't you talk to a merchant
who gives you a map of or gives you
hints on where all this stuff is right
forgot his name yeah he's in like a we
call it a stall somewhere
I can just make it here I guess there is
Guardians and well I know they're nearby
but not here
I shouldn't have fog of the fog is still
over the map around here I got the power
up there no that's really far without
there that's where Guardians are like
even drowning is something I was
forgetting about I had a slip where well
fairies help then No oh yeah you almost
drowned last time well it's it's easy to
drown like I was going for one of these
air ramps or air lifts and if I slipped
by using all my stamina your instant
you're instantly dead I don't I know
that's not the mass there's a chest but
that's it it's yeah as this is a tangent
as someone whose favorite game is
majora's mask and like how mythical the
mask is it's it irks me a tiny tiny bit
to be pedantic that you just you could
come across it that easily I I get it
like it's DLC and stuff like I really
don't give a [ __ ] it's cool once I like
and also and you see that this came out
that this game takes place after every
other game yeah in like V and there's
there's three splits right yeah so this
it's the it's it's three dials adult
linked dies and then link lives and he
stays a child and then link lives and
stays an adult and then this is after
everything although I really don't never
think Nintendo knew what they were doing
it oh they were just BS and probably
yeah we plan that totally intentional
yikes oh I don't know if you saw him I
can learn my way and kill them who the
camp they're having a party you might
not let me do have any and their arrows
to you to blow them up I don't know oh
oh they're looking for ya he saw me you
need fire arrows or bomb arrows right to
light those uh yeah or lor bomb I could
throw a bomb at him just do it I can do
it could probably roll and reach him
from right here right over the rock
still got that Archer up top to worry
about oh that's good nice are they close
enough oh [ __ ]
I don't know I'm doing I should I just
keep going there's probably something in
here uh-oh
I love that those bombs are making their
way into Smash Bros ultimate yeah
Oh what
yeah that standardized no I'm like I'm
still on these arrows would be great
what my hunting in this game always felt
so weird
yeah I admit I'm a wuss when it comes to
like hunting stuff but and I did it in
this game it just felt weird for the
velvet game cuz Far Cry was so
ridiculous that like shooting a mountain
lion to upgrade your inventory didn't
feel all that out of place yeah oh so
you just do that so the other thing is
temporary stamina you get many ways but
like I suck yeah after rocks are pretty
accurate this you can get it from I
think the best way I saw it was double
checking on was tireless frogs all right
and you cook those for an elixir but are
they more concentrated in one area I
forgot
ponds they're really just old yeah but
yeah you're right like in certain like
Acala regions I believe there's like a
lot of kind of marshy shallows like
northeast yes yeah autumn autumnal
forest yeah and then the other thing was
crickets is what I was looking for her
but what someone was saying but why are
you cutting that because that's where
crickets would be Oh gotcha but crickets
also there's a oh yeah what you doing
you silly Cora wait so the cork mask
just increases the range where you can
hear stuff yeah like I could even go for
more DLC stuff and get better armor like
because I don't have
Oh have you upgraded any inventory up
with seeds I got to I got I believe a
shield and a weapon slot no maybe it was
maybe just all weapons alright I think
I'm on the right path towards right
where's a stable
there you go oh no that was the castle
over this hill I know actually I think
that's right that's the other thing too
is without unlocking the tower just
definitely a little tricky to gauge
where you are
the the Ferren tropical I know what you
call it tropical yeah there's tons like
it's always raining it's so hard to
climb any foe right and there's
lightning that's nothing to is I could
easily sled or shield surf and break a
shield Oh perfect bored as hell
Wow there's beetle dude
oh good I can buy some arrows from him I
have to sell some stuff I was actually
gonna ask like because the damage of the
shield more to surf on like rocks and
stuff right yeah I think I've heard
grass is okay but clearly not snow and
sand our very best bets
okay so let's sell some crap here just
keep thinking of so many things I wanna
do like like just progress Lionel's are
gonna like gold Lionel's to like they'll
see you oh they'll see you and just like
they'll see you and launch like I know
it depends on the Lionel but like some
of them just have like massive fire
bombs they can he uses so far away like
those are really precise as well
[Music]
sound a lot of monster parts I notice
yeah those are the one things like you
know they're for elixirs and I could I
can get those fairly easy how much all
right there's tireless frog hundred
freakin rupees deep nope whoa I should
help nope see ya ya dance decent I think
I might be able to get one more weapon
slot cuz it's exponential right Oh -
okay so maybe I was right maybe I'd to
get a shield slot did you want to see
that I just said I love this dance I
hate it
fine I'll play it again for this other
one I can do it so then I didn't den I
don't know I could get I don't think you
need another bow right I just want a
weapon yeah
damn short yeah mmm baby yes good ok
[Music]
Oh Oh just but stall with the inner cap
yeah really want it's stallion but I
don't need your tips
there's always some goodies remember to
like a pot lid yeah I'll do it again and
here we come
cook those shrooms herb I do a lot of
cooking in my free time I wish cooking
was that easy you just know how fine
throw mushrooms and meat and apples
together I mean I guess it could be that
easy if you want to eat something
disgusting rush temporary movement speed
sure
a little acorn delish give it a little
nutmeg e flavor I'll call it there you
cook fairies I don't know if it's worth
it though uh you you know be actually
making it a lot easier if you do the
pilot that Guardian trick oh yeah sure
we put a video up a few years ago last
year people still love it you can tell
by the grammar that is just kids what's
what the Frick is didn't work the Frick
okay sorry what is that objective marker
right now
oh hi tato village locked memory
mementos so it's just asking me to go
take pictures which I'm not gonna do
okay so I'm gonna go just right halfway
through the episode for today so you
doing pretty well yeah a lot of prep
this is gonna be it though this is gonna
be the ultimate test what's down there
it's I'm sorry this Farren the area
there frogs to get her durians there's
there's this a lot of climbing it's hard
to climb and I'm worried I won't be able
to get to the tower yeah there because
of the rain and stuff like I might need
to find a way to to get to gain
elevation and then like left to get
elevation like off cliffs and then hit
the tower I think it's probably the best
bet do you think the majora's mask is
cheap I can take it off I'm just
thinking like that kind of maybe yeah I
mean it kind of defeats the purpose of
Master mode that doesn't defeat the
whole purpose I mean maybe well maybe
the comments hold the comments decide
it's just making most enemies besides
miles and the Guardians ignore you right
yeah yeah I'd say it is takeoff
you got four ferries just fine yeah
let's take off
yeah well yeah we're still learning so
if anyone has any comments like do put
them in there mum's honest well Jess
okay so that is Ferren tower i believe
and they have just gone the wrong way
just jump it swim yeah my horsing is not
I didn't use horse as much during my
first playthrough eventually you don't
you know with like warping around
get up there I mean I'm like well my
finest memories was like just going like
I was thinking I could just like go up
like really early on like oh I'll just
go around this whole mountain and like
brought my horse and my horse died just
I baked pretty much just like froze to
death like I had to abort my whole thing
it was just like thinking I could do
that that's how your head couple Flo
Cobbs horse really likes you
oh there's no way so yeah I know I
killed those guys so I haven't had a
Blood Moon yet
I think the fastest way would be across
those platforms right bridge yeah
now I don't have a horse wait why
couldn't you summon him the summoning is
not that great you just have to be
within semi-closed right like he oh and
the knee is stable yeah this is like the
next I like weapons is what I'm worried
about now they're like not having enough
yeah like I'm worried about like good
weapons yeah yeah once you have now seen
blazing I really want to know what's
down there cuz I don't think I've ever
seen that for oh it's a yeah yeah but
stop Wow loved it are you gonna try to
unlock the tower while you here or maybe
that's not I don't think that's fair it
no that's Lake that's the lake tower
Oh regardless I'm still going around
here Oh
oh I hear it
oh there it is that's our guy
palm trees and [ __ ] okay cool so yeah
I'm just gonna start hugging the web's
here it's cookie this could get dicey in
the forest it really could there's one
ferry down oh man ah that was so quick
get away from him oh no sorry but stop
Oh God
oh my God thank God for that berries you
got he didn't do that yep that would
have been middle croissant that would
have been totally it oh man we gotta I
feel like every time I say something bad
could happen it happens yeah god I was
brutal
a [ __ ] electric he's just
clotheslined you those guys suck is that
a Whizzer other wizzrobe yeah that's
right okay I think I'm gonna need to
start going on foot here what's that
guy's name cast oh yeah I think I'm
gonna need to go on foot I like at this
point it's just like yeah he's got a
good weapon though cast know that was
electric yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] idiot oh maybe alright I also
just alerted someone that above you yeah
nevermind I know that game even having
this map revealed would help with for
like elevation it seems but stall isn't
able to come this game makes me fifteen
again cool so you go into the tower
right now yeah is it always raining or
just much much more frequently it
happens all the goddamn time and it's
gonna happen right when I get like
halfway through a clown there anyway to
avoid the cliffs
no I mean not now okay going this way
actually ooh that's good that's right
there's bunt there's a bunch of bananas
these are gonna cook these I get don't
have to fight hack onus me a clan for
him yeah oh is it a rabbit thing money
that's good that's good that's good yeah
she scared the crap out of me I got some
wings all right that's all questions at
all cliff I could maybe do a little
babies up here baby steps to the tower
not jump either come here hey well you
went down easy yeah
could you do like a lateral thing oh so
I get like the tower is I remember being
a real [ __ ] to climb so like you can
definitely get to it you know you can
shorten the distance by paragliding
right like I want to get high of where
I'm comfortable but then you weren't you
worried that if you paraglide too far
you still use not the same stamina which
I don't that's true you'd use it up more
slowly when you're gliding but yeah I
would want to do it when I'm like full
[Applause]
nope don't even higher yeah there's a
Ledge there okay yeah you're past the
point of no return now that's not a
Ledge no it's not really alleges it I
just say abort even that fall was a
little risky you see the ground oh I
think there's a line all around here
cold known everybody opposite so can you
eat something for salmon on the way up I
mean I don't have jack [ __ ] I thought
you got no yeah no it was 100 rupees for
the Frog
[ __ ] goat I think you're good I think
I'm good yeah just don't jump
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god just turns back to the camera
[ __ ] Iran oh there's a [ __ ] - for your
troubles
please you stupid [ __ ] yeah there's
definitely ok so there's there's 2 here
so this there's a he knocks here god I
know this game way too well and then
there's an up there is a Lionel have you
thought I can't you haven't finally he
talks yet I don't want to know I never
mind it's the next one so next one would
be nope nope I was right don't doubt
your instincts now [ __ ] it kill him no
just kidding
probably got some decent weapons but oh
what am i doing the towers are over here
I'm good I could do this yeah just start
from vet him
wait you could try stuffing up and
taking his weapons you got a lot of
fairies right worst-case scenario you
sprint away and then jump off the cliff
yeah so do you have to climb of his feet
is that it there's a trick no there's a
trick I saw where you can
so we scratches his uh when he scratches
his belly right you can ride his hand up
like a damn elevator yeah he's got some
sort he's got good stuff oh yeah just
run away
Oh durian isn't that what you came here
for yeah but there's a collection of
them over here that's legit could I pass
the towel where's the tower that way
this way yes your glial of it yeah I'm
good
it's right there oh there it is is that
it yeah that's it just go back
run go sorry
oh there's those guys too
all right worked out nice that was
textbook damn these guys might be tough
there's two lizalfos I want to kill and
then I can get all those durians what do
you why you can go there near the
durians yeah
[Music]
that's not a bad idea though that's a
good way to get like I know where a
bunch of Phoenix's are like we could
just stealth collect a bunch of weapons
from them what did you do wrong that
time just the jump you didn't aim Eric I
kind of washed out I could have waited
okay for him to like chill out and go
back to sleep
but I think I jumped I don't know how
else we'd get on his hand without
jumping I could walk onto it yeah I
should walk on her that wasn't even even
tie-dye one down there was it alright
alright so let's party with them BYO w
weapons bring out the big guns
the pylon my shield and with this what
are they using oh so they're show their
stuff is there so they got boomerangs
those are durians right there oh they're
everywhere in this area this is the
money farm spot as well as mighty
thistle so like that's good for attack
op oh okay getting it the rain held off
man you really don't have great weapons
you know I don't
oh nice nice easily recharge their help
oh [ __ ] yeah that's right oh he's stuck
all right fine now he's gonna get out of
there back oh did he punch you in real
life you're stabbing us man he's almost
got his health back to use Darien's
worth oh that really messed him up
that oh I don't know if that's worth the
stamina these guys are I'm bleeding
weapons hi guys help stayed nice yeah I
know honey this is just a reminder you
seem like you you need any help you need
help
oh you got a spear nice does the other
100 just so you know if you do a perfect
dodge yeah you got it right the other
one's pretty low
yeah bombs no [ __ ] oh my god no
[Laughter]
okay it wasn't textbook but it was those
are worth I think oh he dropped one two
or that was that was in the air where he
died that was right here
why'd you drop it
show yourself he is stupid wait why
didn't that work the first time you meet
it to my other families right absolutely
picked it up yeah bye-bye you get that
twig I don't know if I should be doing
that keep you aligned the trees and just
grab them yeah but it's raining and that
takes a damn long time it's like five
feet tall there are a lot of those here
oh yeah and crickets nice this is worth
this was worth it yeah definitely got a
tower
this area is still chugging source frame
where it goes yeah there's so much good
so what makes it so good the three
hearts they give you or yeah I'll show
you you um you cook one you get max
hearts which doesn't make much of a
difference with three hearts but it also
gives me temporary hearts so if I go you
cook five of these I'm rocking like
fifteen hearts yeah like a whole bunch
just so you're aware you've like 13
minutes for 12 minutes left okay cool I
don't know if you want to do one more
like thing well I'm gonna go this was
definitely a big step I'd say let's go
back that he niché's you gonna go for
his web he had what you want to call it
he had a decent-looking sword was it a
Royal I believe the Royal sword it
looked like a bra final sword oh now
they generally have like royal broad
swords and bows
the gold royal gear I always try to go
from
I don't even selling stuff
now you say that now you send the
episode of the top of the cliff what is
this to come off what oh yeah yeah on
vacay here
it's Denver I always say that it bleeds
so fast I think you're gonna tie it
perfectly again yeah as much as I love
the climbing like two didn't link ever
hear the concept of like resting on the
rocks
oh nice no right least you got that I
mean that well you just what did I save
maybe I don't know I feet maybe that
will account for what I lost there is
there a Ledge
I'm good I'm good
oh I could rest on that route could you
I think so but you pretty much just
committed to it anyway I mean how much
time I really saving diagonally oh yeah
I got this oh for sure corrected good
job all right mess up this he knocks
ever
there's Turing's right here - yeah so I
think I could just walk on it I don't
even know if this does eliminate more of
my noise but I like to think it does who
do you even need to crouch just walk
slowly will that cuz I don't think you
can get on to him while you're crouching
right no I think I could just walk
slowly
wellhow lunges don't expend his whatever
yeah
the old his arm almost crushed me too
that'll do it hey get some durians
before you paraglide off a bee sting
freakin nothing
[Music]
Oh Oh maybe I could pair a glide onto
him
yeah you see you come up here whoa
you're kind of close to it
I think I could do it
that will make too much noise happy no
even if it does wake him up you slow
now let's yeah I want to make sure I
don't have anything
damn you guys 60 nose Darien's yeah
that's a lot
Stoke go back
[Music]
which you're rocking here big boy you
got around your neck want to see what's
your traffic Oh sleepy time huh oh my
god just go to bed I don't know if this
is high enough I really don't think so I
can get up from here yeah I think you're
good it's it's tight it's close if I
went up a little more yeah I'd double
down just go up this is a tall cliff oh
[Laughter]
yeah there's everything you jump to that
thing probably see way taller I was
risking yeah he shoots I'll give you a
hundred bucks if you try to fight it
right now
just so you know you only have like two
empty sword slots I thought that should
he can't have more than two so already
go he's right there hasn't spawned in
because this game sucks
worth it all right nice what an idiot
nice
[Laughter]
[ __ ] now you're just showing off
there is a a what as our a Oz stable
oh there's a yeah I remember this shrine
took me a while to find behind those
yeah it's tricky yeah yeah it's probably
at that too we're wrapping up right yeah
four minutes don't die in the next four
minutes and it is Zelda o clock
at the new news my biggest fear is bombs
will be the one that will kill me I
don't kill myself use one fairy write
that electric keys for minutes
I cook a backup for what are you doing
next time oh great
next time I don't know you got a lot of
durian I mean I think I want to find
some more weapons another he knocks I
could find another he knocks I could
find a there's armor for the DLC armor
you could look for if you want to right
right
like the Phantom armor yeah for anyone
watching also if you have any tips I
want to read them because I think what I
might do is I might find out we're like
the the highest level he knocks our I
believe there are some I think in the
honor there's like I was right yeah
they're kind of scattered over place
they would I would bet have the best
weapons around their neck Oh his name is
but stall could you go find him for me
thanks but stop creator today hey can
you grab a beetle now you have a few
more groups oh I think that frog energy
or whatever thought just expensive
though I really want arrows for most
part like the other thing I'm thinking
is like I want to find
damnit I want to find where all of the
ancient arrow Ches are like there are
couple in the castle I want to get okay
that'll help kill gammy you can't even
get the Hylian Shield till you're in the
castle right
damn I'll ensure I have to beat that
stall I don't know it's a stall bone
Phoenix she's guarding the hylians 100%
worth it just so you don't have to worry
about shielding yeah dude
but again you'd have to get a you have
to get by all those Guardians first I
can I can behind next episode
maybe the shield no first anything your
arrows though ancient arrows yeah I
would I can come back to him later
all right I only picked up one call old
school this is I had a sweet fire weapon
I could do this instantly but no sir
please don't start a fire inside the
building oh I'm gonna watch sir what the
[ __ ] John we're Flint I don't think so
hopefully it's no I did you wait good
morning so it's not raining hopefully
and I could cook outside did you use
your last wood - oh no Flint isn't like
a little child you can help me out here
you called this is stable
don't they light this on fire maybe
later in the day but you just use your
fun you can't wait yeah I would have to
like go away I guess
ooh last thing will do no I don't have
enough pieces of meat do I to make what
this dog show me some good stuff
I don't know I mean I guess I'll just
I'll save you just call it yeah I don't
know else like a new I was an hour yeah
we'll start the beginning of the episode
and I'll be cooking a bunch of stuff
sweet oh alright well congratulations
sorry yeah it's actually the third time
you've gotten through we've gotten
through an episode intact yeah so that
was a season or episode what six of
Grave hoppers six or seven show where we
put permadeath in every game where it's
every Thursday and like I said we're
still want people to participate
recommending games or in this case
giving Robert tips for Zelda I don't
know like you want to try to go get
ancient arrows next week and the shield
in best-case scenario yeah okay let me
not to do that it'll be tough okay he'll
be tougher we could do it still a few
close calls slash keys to the face so
next meeting next week we're going again
we're going to the castle yeah
in the meantime like I said leave Robson
tips and as always have a good weekend
and we will see you next week same time
same day on Grave hoppers later see you
guys